it's something that I'm constantly
thinking about I'm I'm judged the minute
someone meets me Sarah has struggled
with her weight for her entire adult
life that's more than 20 years of diets
and Weight Management Programs nothing's
worked she hopes mugletide will this is
literally going to change everything
because what it's doing is changing the
physiological makeup of my body so it's
changing my hormones it's changing the
way that the signals are going to my
brain it's changing the way I'm going to
think around food for instance and then
the way that my body thinks around food
and that's going to make such a huge
impact on
just general life so it's different for
everyone also known as wegovi the drug
is a higher dose of a diabetes
medication ozympic it works by
suppressing the patient's appetite the
treatment has exploded in popularity in
the United States sparked by a viral
trend on social media
and endorsements from celebrities like
Elon Musk the drug is used as a reset
moment not as a lifestyle option this is
not a drug to be used for people who are
just trying to look good on the beach
this is a drug for people who are really
wrestling with obesity and need a break
from the pressures of fighting uh with
their with their appetites over the 30
years the percent
clinically obese people in the UK has
increased from around 15 to just under
30 percent obesity is estimated to cause
about 30 000 deaths in the UK each year
the drug will only be offered to
patients on specialist NHS Weight
Management Programs like the ones they
run here at St Thomas's Hospital there
are already serious supply issues with
semoglo Tide with private clinics being
accused of stockpiling the drug
following celebrity endorsements the
drug was first used in diabetes
treatment and now senior doctors have
told us they're worried because diabetes
patients are now at risk because of
access to the drug
Sarah knows she might not get some ugly
tied until the end of the year but after
20 years of battling with their size she
desperately hopes it will be worth the
wait oh she's Joshi Sky News